alors ce matin je me trouvais à moins de
30 kilomètres de la frontière
ukrainienne et la zone commencé à être
bombardées au petit matin quand je dis
la zone ça veut dire ça ne veut pas dire
le côté russe forcément ça veut dire que
la frontière était très près et donc je
commençais à entendre les bombardements
les obus que j'ai entendu il tombait ça
je peux le dire mais je ne sais pas qui
a déclenché les hostilités le premier ce
que je peux dire c'est que actuellement
je suis partie un petit peu plus loin je
suis à une centaine de kilomètres de la
frontière je vois passer des bombardiers
et il faut souligner que je suis en ce
moment dans une zone où on ne se prépare
est absolument pas à ce qu'il y ait une
offensive puisque ce n'est pas la zone
qui se trouve du côté des républiques
séparatistes autoproclamé de donetsk de
lougansk vladimir poutine a reconnu
avant-hier où il a affirmé envoyé son
armée c'est une zone plus au nord en
face de la ville de la deuxième ville
voilà vous entendez peut-être les
bombardiers jean voirin passer
actuellement
donc je suis je disais que je suis dans
cette zone à qui est en face de la ville
de la deuxième plus grande ville
l'ukrainienne du pays kharkiv et
c'est une zone qui est contrôlé par le
gouvernement ukrainien c'est à dire que
c'est n'est pas une zone qui était en
guerre précédemment donc on s'attendait
plutôt à une offensive du côté du
dombass là où vladimir poutine a affirmé
envoyé son armée bien que tout le monde
sait qu'elle était déjà sur place avant
même cette annonce est ici tous et
toutes ces dernières semaines il avait
une très très forte concentration de
troupes d'artillerie on a observé ces
images circulé sur internet et ces
témoignages qui faisaient état de chars
envoyé depuis toutes les régions russes
vers cette région et donc il semblerait
et non pas il semblerait mais on peut
dire à coup sûr puisque je vous dis
avoir entendu les bombardements que les
hostilités ont aussi été déclenchés dans
la zone de kharkiv ensuite la question
étant qu'elle peut être l'ampleur de
cette offensive et l'ampleur des
hostilités vous disiez avoir vu des
images de bombardement sur kiev je n'ai
pas d'information de ce côté là ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que ces derniers
jours des sources paramilitaires m'ont
envoyé des messages très inquiète en me
disant que l'ambition de vladimir
poutine serait d'aller jusqu'en y être
que la taxe se ferait par trois points
côté marioupol c'est-à-dire au sud en
phase donc de cette république
séparatiste autoproclamé de donetsk côté
kharkiv là où je me trouvais un petit
peu plus tôt et où il ya eu des
bombardements et aussi par le bélarus où
il y avait une très impressionnante
concentration de troupes russes et
bélarusses leurs alliés leurs alliés et
donc ça c'est directement au nord de
kiev elena bonjour vous le disiez un ces
bombardements vont finalement pour
l'instant au delà de ce que vladimir
poutine avait en tout cas annoncé même
si ça reste est assez flou delà du
donbass pourquoi cette zone notamment de
kharkiv est elle importante pourquoi
est-ce que l'armée russe a décidé de
venir est d'intervenir ici
parce qu'il s'agit d'après ce qu'on m'a
expliqué en tout cas de sources
paramilitaires dans le commandement ce
serait de couper l'ukraine en deux par
le nièvre
alors il faudrait voir une carte pour
comprendre la géographie mais le vous
savez que la crimée a été annexé en 2014
vladimir poutine a toujours considéré
que historiquement cette terre faisait
partie de la russie depuis qu'elle a
donnée était donné par le dirigeant
soviétique nikita khrouchtchev à
l'ukraine donc ayant annexé cette
péninsule ce qui paraît très probable
c'est qu'ils veulent à rejoindre par
toute la partie terrestre
maintenant il s'agit donc de toute la
zone qui serait à l'est d'une y être on
a entendu la dîmière poutine dans son
discours c'était c'était avant-hier où
il ya deux jours le soir très tard
lorsqu'il a dit que la russie qui
historiquement l'ukraine était un pays
qui n'existait pas qu'il avait été créée
par la russie que l'historiquement les
frontières de la russie était celle de
l' empire que lénine était responsable
d'avoir créé des états au sein de
l'union soviétique et que l'union
soviétique aurait dû être un seul pays
avec des régions autonomes comme
l'aurait voulu le dictateur soviétique
joseph staline donc ayant entendu ce
discours est entendue les menaces de
vladimir poutine qui a directement dit
vous voulez la décommunisation nous
allons vous montrer ce qu'est la
décommunisation en ukraine il faisait là
référence au fait que depuis 2014 et
depuis qu'il a sans l'avouer déclenché
les hostilités dans le dombass et bien
les ukrainiens ont voulu s'affirmer ils
ont voulu renier leur passé soviétique
ils ont commencé à battre les statues de
lénine qui donc selon vladimir poutine
leur avait donné l'indépendance est
qu'ils auraient dû être reconnaissants
et donc la dîmière poutine
poursuit là quelque chose qui ressemble
à une restauration de la grandeur oublié
de l'urss il
il l'a dit il l'a dit il ya quelques
années là pour lui les rsa c'est la plus
grande catastrophe géopolitique du 20e
siècle la chute de l'urss pardon et le
discours qu'il a prononcé qu'on a
entendu ce devait être le second la
seconde grande référence au fait que il
voulait restaurer l'union soviétique
mais non pas comme il existait comme il
existait avec des états indépendants à
l'intérieur mais comme comme un empire
en attendant dans les frontières de
l'empiré russe alors ça c'est des grands
discours c'est extrêmement ambitieux
mais on voit peu concrètement il est en
train de d'essayer de reconquérir
l'ukraine c'est c'est vraiment hormis le
fait que cette guerre risque d'être très
violente et très
très sanglante d'un point de vue
humanitaire
il ya aussi un problème par rapport à
l'opinion publique des populations sur
place puisque toute la partie toute la
partie ouest en dehors de ces régions du
dombass elle est clairement acquise à
l'occident elle est clairement elle
voulait clairement être dans l'europe
elle voulait clair